all great cooks have one thing in common
they practice but before that you need
the right tools to get started hi my
name is Lexus today we're gonna go over
the five essential tools to get you up
and running in the kitchen
then I'm going to show you how to make a
phenomenal bowl of spaghetti and
meatballs using all five components
first things first you're going to need
a chef's knife kitchen knives come in a
ton of different shapes and sizes
however if you're a beginner and 8-inch
chef's knife is the way to go when it
comes to kitchen safety the sharper the
knife the better not only will you be
able to cut ingredients more easily but
it's actually safer than working with a
dull blade a dull knife requires you to
use more force and they have a tendency
to slip while slicing you can get your
knife sharpened by professionals or for
more convenience you can do it at home
yourself for more information check out
our video on how to sharpen a dull knife
now that you have a knife the second
thing you'll need is a proper cutting
board both wood and plastic boards are
great options however if you're just
starting out we recommend going with a
plastic cutting board plastic boards are
typically more affordable they're
extremely easy to clean and require less
maintenance make sure you're using a
cutting board on an even surface and
that it's secure before you start
chopping all you need to do to secure
your board is place a damp paper towel
and lay it underneath to help eliminate
the risk of cross-contamination you can
buy plastic color-coded cutting boards
let's move on to our third kitchen
essential we'd recommend you purchase a
stainless steel frying pan even though
there are so many great options we'd
highly recommend going with a stainless
steel frying pan due to its versatility
and durability whether you're going to
see your steak saute vegetables make
pancakes or fry eggs a stainless steel
pan can really do it all if you're
worried that your food is going to stick
just remember to use enough butter or
oil and to pre-heat your pan to learn
more about stainless steel check out our
previous video all about pans as useful
as pans are they can't cook every dish
you'll need a pot for things like making
soups one pot meals or boiling water for
pasta we recommend getting a four or six
quart stainless steel stockpot these
pots have a variety of uses in the
kitchen for example if you don't happen
to have a deep fryer at home you can use
these to pull off fried chicken corndogs
onion rings and even churros for our
fifth and final essential
let's take advantage of your oven a
rimmed half sheet pan can really take
you far sheet pans can be used to make
roast vegetables baked french fries
chicken wings and it's a super easy way
to reheat pizza they're perfect for your
weekly meal prep as well as baking up
some delicious healthy salmon on the
sweeter side of things you'll use a
sheet pan to bake cookies macarons puff
pastry and slap pies now that we've gone
over the five kitchen essentials we'll
use each of them and show you how to
make a delicious bowl of spaghetti and
meatballs
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]